President Trump is backing away from a
fight in Congress this week over
building in Mexico border wall senior
administration officials tell CBS News
mr. Trump will no longer insist that
this year's budget include money for the
wall that issue threatened a deadlock in
Congress that could have shut down the
government the wall will now be part of
next year's budget instead the president
is moving on to another campaign promise
cutting corporate tax rates Margaret
Brennan is at the White House Margaret
good morning good morning well with just
a few days to go before President Trump
hits that self-imposed 100-day deadline
he is sending a group of top advisors to
Capitol Hill to close some deals
including Treasury secretary minuchin
Gary Cohn and vice president Mike Pence
whose plane touched down on a return
trip from Asia just moments ago I'm
headed back to Capitol Hill there's a
spending bill that's being considered as
we speak
the vice president returned a day early
from his Asia trip to help push through
a spending plan to avoid a government
shutdown
20200 wall doesn't make a lot of sense
without broad-based Republican support
Congress will hold off on financing mr.
Trump's border wall this week the cost
of the wall is staggering for Democrats
and a number of border state Republicans
the wall was a pricey deal-breaker but
they've agreed in principle to more
funding for border security and
surveillance another presidential goal
has been grounded a second attempt to
repeal and replace Obamacare is unlikely
to happen in the next few days we can't
make people vote but we've made
significant progress asked why the
president has not worked with Congress
to pass the ten pieces of legislation he
promised in his first 100 days press
secretary Sean Spicer instead pointed to
the 30 to executive orders mr. Trump
will have signed off on by Friday that's
the most of any president since World
War two I think you have to look at it
in totality of what he actually did get
done mr. Trump is also unveiling a tax
reform blueprint Wednesday to cut
corporate tax rates from 35% to 15%
we're reducing new taxes it's similar to
a plan mr. Trump unveiled during the
camp
which the independent Tax Policy Center
estimated would cost the federal
government nearly 2.4 trillion dollars
over a decade
yesterday Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin said the final plan won't add
to the deficit the tax plan will pay for
itself with economic growth while
reality may have grounded many of mr.
Trump's legislative expectations this is
a very special day in the during a very
long distance call mr. Trump
congratulated a somersaulting dr. Peggy
Whitson on breaking the us record for
the most days in space and jokingly set
a deadline for Americans to make it to
Mars well we want to try and do it
during my first term or at worst during
my second term and while the president
has called the 100 day mark a quote
ridiculous standard the White House
launched this website today outlining
and commemorating what they see as their
biggest wins so far Nora it feels like
sweeps week here at the White House all
right Margaret thank you so much